yes yes yes yes
yes aujourd'hui est un grand jour grand
jour grange au grand jour merci merci à
vous tous merci à vous tous d'être super
membros et super nombreux hier soir la
chaîne comptabilise plus de cinquante
mille abonnés cinquante mille à voler
c'est complètement dingue je t'ai fait
une promesse j'avais pris une bonne
résolution au début de cette année
en un an je vous dis on n'est pas un peu
plus de 1 million 700 mille vue sur
cette chaîne est plus de 13000 abonnés à
la fin de l'année 2018
ma bonne résolution mon objectif c'est
qu'on ait atteint les 100 mille abonnés
aujourd'hui c'est la beauté du chemin
les cent mille abonnés sous pas encore
pour tout de suite
j'espère fin d'année c'est vraiment tout
cas l'objectif de cette année 2018 donc
si vous voulez me file un petit coup de
main partager à fond avec tout le monde
partager avec vos amis vos potes vos
mères vos sorts vos grands-mères qui
vous voulez pour qu'on soit toujours
plus nombreux toujours plus nombreuses
sur la chaîne pour parler de teck pour
parler de technologie en règle générale
alors aujourd'hui on parle packtec
aujourd'hui qu'une exception je voulais
vraiment vous remercier parce que ça
fait vraiment plaisir ça qui est des
petits moments comme ça où il faut
savoir s'arrêter et de dire aujourd'hui
sa maman cool parce qu'aujourd'hui je
passe une étape cette fameuse étape des
50000 peut paraître peut-être dérisoire
mais symboliquement ya vraiment quelque
chose c'est à dire ça fait des mois des
mois des mois des mois que je travaille
sur la chaîne ce travail at on travaille
vraiment à fond pour produire une vidéo
par jour pour produire du contenu de
qualité pour essayer de toujours plus
haut fait toujours plus informer le
mieux vous relayer le contenu des fois
c'est mieux des fois c'est un peu moins
bien c'est toujours perfectible en
attendant il ya une vraie évolution et
ça c'est aussi grâce à vous grâce à
votre présence parce que en tant que
créateur on sent pas forcément compte
mais on est vachement seul lâcher dans
une pièce autour de moi vous voyez pas
offert 160° parce que ça m'a forcément
caritas joli tout de suite et encore pas
mal de de taxi pour tout améliorer un
petit peu pour que ce soit plus sympa
que tu sens des 360° avec la caméra mais
on est vachement seul c'est pas ça pour
me plaindre parce que je suis très
heureux car ce que je fais mais au final
le seul retour que j'ai en règle
générale il apparaît que mes proches
c'est avec vous et sage et au travers
des commentaires au travers de tous les
petits messages que vous voulez c'est
que ceux ci soient les réseaux sociaux
sur twitter sur instagram sur facebook
sur linkedin faire un peu partout ça
nous permet d'échanger et ses petits
moments ces messages que vous mais c'est
ça fait partie de la richesse de ce
partage
et ça c'est super chouette d'ailleurs
congé croiser certaines personnes
d'entre vous
la rue aux différentes endroits où j'ai
pu être c'est vraiment un bonheur parce
que ce qui compte aussi ce qui nourrit
aussi créateurs en tout cas moi ce qui
nourrit c'est tous ces moments ces
rencontres où on dit maintien j'ai vu ça
c'est cool ça j'aime ça j'aime pas c'est
cool ce que tu fais c'est pas cool ce
que tu fais c'est pas grave les leaders
4 pouvoir en échanger avec vous ça
change parce que là je vous parle droit
dans les yeux mais en fait je suis en
train de regarder l'objectif de la
caméra alors j'ai une super caméra qui
très joli joli sourire dans la guérite
mais ça remplacera jamais contact humain
et sartre je tenais aujourd'hui à faire
une petite pause pour pouvoir en parler
vous remercier parce que du fond du
coeur vraiment du fond du coeur ça fait
extrêmement plaisir
mon objectif à moi c'est l'être à 100
mille abonnés à la fin de l'année pour
toujours plus nombreux toujours plus
nombreuses on pourra partager cette
passion qu'elle a tech3 partager les
voyages pour partager mes émerveillement
partager mes déceptions et ça pourra
partager avec vous et quand en face il
ya du monde pour vous renvoyez c'est
génial justement je profite du rendez
vous de ces cinquante mille abonnés pour
vous annoncer l'ouverture de ma chaîne
ait d'itv ma chaîne
instagram est déjà une page instagram si
on appelle sa page sur instagram
je vais déjà tout cas un compte
instagram j'en fais partager quelques
photos quelques petits footeux droite à
gauche n'a rien de bien transcendant
là par contre je l'aï vraiment partagée
de la vidéo comme je le fais sur youtube
ça sera pas les mêmes vidéos je vais
mettre sur youtube pour pas avoir de
double autres nouvellement ça n'aurait
pas trop d'intérêt regarder une vidéo à
l'horizontale sur youtube la même vidéo
sakho revient directement sur instagram
non ça va être un contenu différent ça
peut être des coulisses des coulisses
d'un tournage pour des petits moments
que j'ai pas diffusé monsieur tient à
partager avec vous ça peut être plein de
choses alors je sais pas encore
exactement quelle manière ce métier
parce que quelque chose qui est très
nouveau mais j'ai déjà publiées pour
l'instant deux vidéos jeux plutôt
contente parce que c'est un autre moyen
d'expression alors à la quête de cette
vidéo on est 2426 pour être très précis
sur instagram vous invite à venir
rejoindre le conte c'est monsieur
underscore grudge libre rejoint comme ça
en mai qui parle en gros une part
nombreuses
j'aurais bien qu'on atteigne les dix
mille cas très rapidement pour soi plus
cool qui est plus d'interactions quand
vous venez vous abonner je voulais aussi
un lien d'un description vous allez
souriez pas grave
monsieur dans ce corps heureux et vous
allez voir il ya plein de contenus qui
va arriver sur un star s'arrête aussi
super cool j'en profite également de ce
petit moment là vont faire un petit
arrêt sur image une petite pause dans
cette série de vidéos pour vous demander
ce que vous
d mais en règle générale sur la chaîne
youtube sur ce coup ci ce que vous aimez
ce qui vous plaît comme format ce que
vous aimez pas ce que vous souhaiteriez
à voir est ce que vous voulez plus de
vidéos dans ce cadre là qui aujourd'hui
mon cadre un petit peu plus standard est
ce que vous voulez plus de vidéos à
l'extérieur ou comme la vidéo par
exemple sur le hanafi de parole où je
peux attester le drone à l'extérieur est
ce que vous voulez plus de vidéos dans
la rue dites moi ce que vous voulez ce
qui vous ferait plaisir
[Musique]
ce que vous aimez ce que vous aimez part
est-ce que vous l'express toujours plus
de smartphones est ce que vous avez
d'autres produits est ce que vous allez
voir des ordinateurs portables est ce
que je vais voir des tablettes que j'ai
gardé des appareils photo des réflexes
le ragoût squibb a donc marqué tout ça
parce que les surprises et l'évolution
ne sont pas terminés et loin de là à
partir du début septembre débute début
début septembre il y avoir un tout
nouveau format qui va arriver pour un
peu trancher avec ce que j'ai fait
dernièrement alors on regarde toujours
par l'etec toujours de la même manière
on va garder toujours la même ligne
éditoriale mais on va aller plus loin
prendre les choses plus dynamique plus
vivante
je sais déjà ce que je veux faire j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup travaillé
depuis plusieurs mois mais j'ai aussi
savoir ce qui vous ferait plaisir vous
comme ça pour intégrer toutes ces idées
directement à ce projet parce que ce
projet c'est bien mais c'est aussi le
même parce que je partage avec vous donc
marquons moyens et comment tout ce que
vous voulez tout ce qui vous ferait
plaisir en bas en commentaire je vous
dis encore une fois merci merci merci
beaucoup à vous tout à vous tous je sais
qu'il ya une grosse audience masculine
voit bien que si une audience féminine
qui viennent parce que latex quelque
chose d'extrêmement mixe les hommes et
les femmes
tout le monde s'intéresse à l'attaquant
on a tous dans nos poches sans
smartphone qui est le premier objet
technologique on possède tous certains
ont des watch on a tous quasiment des
ordinateurs beaucoup ont des tablettes
quelle que soit la marque donc la
technologie nous concerne tous
aujourd'hui la communauté masculine est
extrêmement représenté sur la chaîne
j'aimerais bien qu'ils aussi beaucoup
plus de communautés féminines comme ça
touche de féminité ça fait toujours du
bien
merci en tout cas une fois de plus 50
mille fois merci merci merci
on fera d'autres pour réguliers aux
grandes étapes comme ça et puis je pense
que pour les cent mille abonnés on se
fera un grand truc on se fera un grand
truc je sais pas quoi ça arrivera
probablement d'ici la fin de l'année
peut-être tout début d'année prochaine
tu vas vraiment ce soir fin d'année
parce que c'est l'objectif de cette fin
d'année au 31 décembre à 23h59 et 59
secondes
tous les cons dépasser les cent mille
abonnés ça aussi je compte sur vous si
vous voulez m'aider en faisant le relais
autour de vos amis vos proches pour ans
a toujours hyper nombreux et hyper
nombreuses merci merci merci merci
beaucoup j'attends tous vos avis en
commentaire de tous les lire un parent
je vais essayer de vous répondre à tous
individuellement je vais essayer parce
que si vous êtes si émile commentaires
très rapidement ça va être compliqué
mais j'ai vraiment prendre le temps
cette fois ci dans cette vidéo de faire
vraiment l'effort de répondre à tout le
monde
individuellement donc marquer moi tout
ce que vous voulez directement en bas en
commentaire je prends le temps de vous
répondre
merci à vous merci
cinquante mille fois merci énormément
vous êtes tous géniaux
je vous ai énormément et je vous dis à
très les officiers on se croise on
détourne le trottoir d'une rue n'importe
où quel que soit le moment les faire un
petit coucou un petit salut une petite
bise on se filme avec les caméras on se
met sur youtube puissance enfin la ccl
l'amour c'est génial que voici
à très bientôt vous embrasse soyez sages
prenez soin de vous et je vous embrasse
toutes faites plus tôt
[Musique]